[Music]
in 1942 a mother daughter duo
catherine cook briggs and isabelle
briggs myers developed a questionnaire
that classified people's personalities
into 16 types
called the myers-briggs type indicator
or mvti
it would go on to become one of the
world's most widely used personality
tests
today personality testing is a
multi-billion dollar industry
used by individuals schools and
companies
but none of these tests including the
mbti the big five
the disc assessment the process
communication model
and the enneagram actually reveal truths
about personality
in fact it's up for debate whether
personality is a stable
measurable feature of an individual at
all
part of the problem is the way the tests
are constructed each is based on a
different set of metrics to define
personality the myers-briggs for
instance focuses on features like
introversion and extroversion to
classify people into personality
types while the big five scores
participants on five
different traits most are self-reported
meaning the results are based on
questions participants answer
about themselves so it's easy to lie
but even with the best intentions
objective self-evaluation
is tricky take this question from the
big five
how would you rate the accuracy of the
statement
i am always prepared there's a clear
favorable answer here
which makes it difficult to be objective
people subconsciously
aim to please when asked to agree or
disagree
we show a bias towards answering however
we believe the person
or institution asking the question wants
us to answer
here's another question what do you
value more
justice or fairness what about
harmony or forgiveness you may well
value both sides of each pair
but the mbti would force you to choose
one and while it's tempting to assume
the results of that fourth choice
must somehow reveal a true preference
they don't
when faced with the same forced choice
question multiple times
the same person will sometimes change
their answer
given these design flaws it's no
surprise that test results can be
inconsistent one study found that nearly
half of people who take the myers-briggs
a second time
only five weeks after the first get
assigned a different
type and other studies on myers-briggs
have found that people with very similar
scores
end up being placed in different
categories suggesting that the strict
divisions between personality types
don't reflect real life nuances
complicating matters further the
definitions of personality traits are
constantly shifting
the swiss psychiatrist carl jung who
popularized the terms
introvert and extrovert defined an
introvert as someone who sticks to their
principle
regardless of situation and an extrovert
is someone who moulds their self
according to circumstance introversion
later came to mean shyness
while an extrovert was someone outgoing
today
an introvert is someone who finds a lone
time restorative
an extrovert draws energy from social
interaction and an ambivert falls
somewhere between these two extremes
the notion of an innate unchanging
personality
forms the basis of all of these tests
but research
increasingly suggests that personality
shifts during key periods
like our school years or when we start
working though certain features of a
person's behavior
may remain relatively stable over time
others are malleable
molded by our upbringing life
experiences and age
all of this matters more or less
depending on how a personality test is
used
though anyone using them should take the
results with a grain of salt
there isn't much harm in individual use
and users may even learn some new terms
and concepts in the process
but the use of personality tests extends
far beyond self-discovery
schools use them to advise students what
to study
and what jobs to pursue companies use
them to decide who to hire
and for what positions yet the results
don't predict how a person will perform
in a specific role
so by using personality tests this way
institutions can deprive people of
opportunities they'd excel at or
discourage them from considering
certain paths
so what about the infamous raw shark
inkblot test
how does the test work and does it
really work at all
find out where the test comes from and
how psychologists use it with this video
you